michel auger président une soirée sans
suspense et sans surprise le 9 mai
dernier michel laugier est réélu
président du conseil d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
suite à l'annulation du vote du 9
janvier par le tribunal administratif de
versailles avec 43 voix sur 46 suffrages
exprimés le maire de montigny le
bretonneux roccon son poste une partie
des délibérations du mois de janvier est
annulée par le tribunal tout ça parce
que il y avait un filtrage à l'entrée
alors que nous étions dans une situation
d'état d'urgence je trouve qu'on a perdu
beaucoup de temps pour rien parce que
finalement vous voyez que on exactement
dans la même configuration de celle que
nous avions décidé au mois de janvier
donc on a perdu du temps on a perdu de
l'argent et je pense qu' il est grand
temps de se mettre au travail dans
l'intérêt des saint quentinois joséphine
coleman ce berger reprend la première
vice-présidence aucun changement pour
les onze vice-présidents
en revanche le vote s'est déroulé sans
la gauche qui a refusé d'y prendre part
en restant en retrait pendant toute la
durée de l'élection des vice-présidents
et à certains votes auxquels on n'a pas
participé tout ce qui concerne l
exécutif puisque de nouveaux on en est
exclue cire que l'on considère qu'il ya
des communes qui mérite d'être
représentés avec des vrais délégation
puis aller sous commune
on espérait que cette deuxième élection
allait permettre de remettre les choses
à plat c'est pas le cas on le regrette
parce que c'était un petit peu
l'occasion de repartir sur de meilleures
bases
la gauche conserve des postes de
conseillers communautaires
selon la représentation politique du
conseil d'agglomération ne serait pas
équitable
pointé du doigt par la droite lors du
conseil le coût de ces élections aux
contribuables saint quentinois